وفي ظهور صاخب كالعاده قدم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب نفسه كمرشح رئيسيا وحيد قادر
على ما وصفه بمهمه انقاذ الولايات المتحده
ممن يكرهونها ترامب الذي كان يتحدث في
المؤتمر السنوي للمحافظين الامريكيين لم
يدخر جهدا في مهاجمه كل خصومه الحاليين
والمفترضين مستقبلا حتى داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
كان لدينا حزب جمهوري يحكمه غريب اطوار
ومحافظون جدد ومؤيد وعولمه ومتعصب حدود
مفتوحه واغبياء لكننا لن نعود ابدا الى
حزب بور ريان وكايروف وجيب بوش
ترامبا لم يقدر نفسه كمنقذ لامريكا فقط
وانما كمنقذ للعالم من خطر الحرب العالميه
الثالثه التي تقترب بحسب اعتقاده
باي لكني اقف هنا اليوم وانا المرشح
الوحيد القادر على الوفاء بهذا الوعد
وسامع وبكل سهوله الحرب العالميه الثالثه
بسهوله شديده
خطاب وترام تستغرق ساعه واربعين دقيقه لذا
كان هناك متسع من الوقت للاشاره الى ان
الامريكيين السائموا من عائلات سياسيه
متجذره في الحزبين ومن مصالح خاصه متعفنه
وسياسيين محبين للصين وانصار حروب خارجيه
لنهايه لها طبعا كل هذا بحسب وصفه اما
اللافت ان الاجتماعات من هذا النوع كانت
في العاده ما تشهد مقاعد خاويه لكن خلال
خطاب ترامب كانت القاعه تقريبا ممتلئه
ابرز المتغيبين على الاجتماع كان مايك بنز
نائب الرئيس في عهد ترامب وحكم فلوريدا
روندا
على الاغلب لتجنب مصير نكهه فالسفير
السابقه لدى الامم المتحده قبلت بوابل من
صيحات الاستهجان اثناء ظهورها في المؤتمر
وبعده كونها الوحيده التي اعلنت حتى الان
ترشحها لمنافسه ترامب على الفوز بترشيح
الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه لكن من الواضح انه
لا هالي ولا بانس يمثلان هاجس هاجسا لدى
ترامب وانما روندا حاكم فلوريدا شاب ولذا
حرص ترامب على تذكير الحضور بانه متفوق
بنسبه 62% مقابل 20% على
استطلاع الراي الذي اجري خلال المؤتمر شيء
اخر في هذا المؤتمر بلاغه ترامب التي لم
يكن يركز عليها سابقا فقد خاطب الحشود
قائلا في 2016 قلت انا صوتكم واليوم اضيف
انا محاربكم انا عدلكم وللذين تعرضوا
للظلم والخيانه انا قصاصكم